okay you get the cool suit and buy cool
I mean cumbersome and derivative don't
take it too hard
I mean clearly as you can see I'm kind
of a costume design snob okay fine it's
a nice suit sorry gee
oh man Marco this is so getting old
where's your partner
hey don't think I need a partner anymore
what just happened
I have salmon now that's just law
oh no no no no not a good time to run
out of West
yes on a reality show at the changing
faces completely ridiculous makeovers
nice huh
the big man did this to me to get to you
Nate man who's the big man uh you
thought that's need-to-know only look
cleaning your clocks been fun but I got
thanks to rob
ah man my money okay forget football as
soon as school's out I'm webbing up
Sandman one city nice move yesterday
Kurt it's down to you Harry and Hobie
Brown
now what am I going to do I've got to
track him down maybe I can find a clue
at his old apartment that symbiote
nearly drove me nuts I can only imagine
what it's going to do to a pumped-up
lunatic like Brock pump up that's it
Brock likes to work out by himself all
the time and that might just give me the
lead I need
I want you to know I realized that
coming in here sneaking in here in the
middle of the night twice no less was
not fair to you you were honest with me
and you showed me this thing and I in
return I stepped on you and I'm sorry
you gotta believe me I am so sorry I
swear I was going to sit down and really
talk to you about this but after I got
rid of it I wasn't going to leave you
hanging but the fact of the matter is
that I've had run-ins with situations
like this men men stronger and smarter
than both of us who find themselves with
something like this some source of
untested power and I've seen them
destroy themselves their family
everything I'm not kidding literally
destroy themselves you've read the
papers right you've seen some of the
stuff I came up again let's just some of
it that should part of the story this is
a seriously twisted world we live in all
of a sudden it's like everybody is
trying to be more than they are everyone
trying to accelerate the process of of I
don't know what and now to think that
both of our fathers may have
inadvertently done the very same thing
10 years before anyone else it just I
can't handle it Eddie I can't let this
be I'm saying I know how bad this can go
I'm not guessing I know firsthand I know
this will go badly if you don't destroy
this and the fact that I know all of
this that I have seen all the horrible
crap that I've seen and I still thought
that I could do something with this I
mean the arrogance with me to think that
I can well I I'm just disgusted with
myself on levels you can't even imagine
this is a freakish genetic mutation this
is unnatural this is uncontrollable it
has to go
what no acceptance speech you didn't
thank your manager your agent your
assistant your shrink the Dalai Lama I'm
a witch what can I tell you so you had
some sudden need for a paperweight or is
there some big market for stolen cable
TV Awards okay first of all spandex you
might want to think that second not
everything's about money sweetheart if
it's worth something to them it's worth
something to me and third
[Music]
okay that was humiliating and this is
still not standing
out calling you at 10 o'clock two
minutes from now Robbie I have to talk
to you not now Peter it's about dr.
octopus listen kid we don't have time
you don't understand I know him he was
my teacher we're professionals we know
how to deal with these situations but I
think I know how to get to him no no way
let's hear him out
we're tampering with the most important
thing in Octavius life science unless we
understand that Felicia and mr. Jameson
will be let me talk to him hello dr.
Octavius
this is Peter Parker I was one of your
students years ago at science camp
mm-hmm
probably don't remember me but you
taught me how important science I've
read hammering pre-published
a sustained fission fusion reactions
zero chemical fusion Collider
you never loved that you passed two of
my cold fusion battery of course I'd
give anything to see that battery and
you're the perfect one to bring me the
ransom and on that I'll show it to you
[Music]
usually it's the spider that traps the
fly not the octopus that traps the
spider
she's a good woman I sometimes think
there isn't a sonar in existence that
can sound out the depth of her
compassion but right now that isn't what
I need what I need to get away and up
and out
just out I needn't care where I go I
just want to go I'm not going to stop
until I get tired unfortunately it takes
a real long time for me to get tired by
that time I could be in New Jersey I
don't even know anybody in New Jersey
and here's another thing when I designed
this suit why the heck didn't I design
it with pocket anything I carry I got to
carry it in a web pouch yep F has
pockets in their uniforms Reed Richards
alone are huge that's because he has to
carry transdimensional mega doodad and
really booze in them or maybe he's just
really heavy a Sisu of course if I had
pocket stuff would fall out of them
every time I did this okay so maybe I
can have pockets with zippers
maybe velcro check that it worked
I'd be creeping up behind somebody and
have to get something out what's that
smear on the wall mommy that used to be
spider-man honey what killed him a
zipper some said velcro but the Daily
Bugle says it was a zipper and I believe
the bugle wow he must've been real
stilted huh yes honey he was why the
heck am i singing about pockets anyway
because it's easier than thinking about
my life lately and why should that
bother you Peter oh no reason
everything's fine everything's just done
except that whenever I'm really loved
about something I really need to go
found a bad guy ders never a bad guy
around but whenever I'm in a really good
mood
yeah like that happens more than twice a
year there's always four or five bad guy
for a tennis
or seven or nineteen waiting to bust my
chops until with my face bug spider-man
made of funny
he night there go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you